well more now on our top story those
reports suggesting that the iso leader
abu bakr al-baghdadi has been killed in
a u.s
raid al jazeera's osama bin javed joins
us live from san leuerfe that's near
turkey's border
with syria osama said what more details
are you hearing there
about these reports that say the isa
leader has been killed
well darren most of these details are
coming from unnamed u.s military sources
that
a raid was carried out in idlib province
in the northwestern part of syria
about somewhere between five to six
kilometers
or under uh near the turkey border uh
these sources claiming that a joint
special operations command force
known as jsok carried out this operation
they had intelligence they went in
they went into a compound and a person
uh
detonated himself with the suicide vest
now sources in the u.s military believe
that this was abu bakr
al-baghdadi this is something that they
had been working on for days this wasn't
that just happened yesterday
it took a long time coming and it has
also been
uh somewhat made more prominent by us
president donald trump saying that he
has a major announcement to make we've
been hearing
uh from various u.s sources that the
defense secretary is going to be making
a special appearance he wasn't scheduled
to be on any talk shows today he's going
to be
telling the media and the american
public about the development in
northwestern syria
but according to these unnamed u.s
sources abu bakr al-baghdadi
has been killed now this is waiting for
confirmation from dna and biometrics
test
and we know that abu bakr al-baghdadi
had been had not been seen in public
since 2014
when he made that famous speech and came
up on the podium
in mosul and declared that islamic state
of iraq and the levant has been formed
since the fall of isil in the last few
years there have been reports of outer
vertical
many raids happening against them there
have been multiple
rumors about his health about how he was
injured
but it is very interesting that if this
true he's been found
in an area where another group was
fighting for control from
isil and had taken control from isil
this is in the idlib province
where fighters uh close to al-qaeda
risham formerly known as jabata nusra
are predominantly located
so it is an unfolding situation where we
are getting reports from u.s officials
so far no official confirmation we're
waiting for the u.s president
hopefully to make that announcement at 9
00 a.m eastern
osama just very quickly i mean how
significant is all of this given that uh
president trump announced over a year
ago
that the isil caliphate had been
defeated
absolutely so as you've as you've seen
in previous operations
against international groups uh the
killing of osama bin laden took ten
years in the making we've
we saw years and years before they went
in and actually captured saddam hussein
who
was wanted for crimes in iraq so
abubakal baghdadi is going to be a
significant blow
especially psychologically to this
organization which has been defeated
but again you have to see it in context
this is an organization
which fuels from the insurgency which
exists in this part of the world
taking its uh its recruits uh from the
disenfranchisement from the poverty from
the lack of opportunities
from the state heavy-handedness which
again exists in many parts including
iraq and syria
this is where isil found a majority of
its recruits from
but it has lost the capability of luring
foreign recruits saying
that it had a caliphate a state
that was something which brought
together a lot of
radical fighters from all over the world
so it is going to be
a major blow to isil but again the group
has been disintegrating
for the last few years now what is left
is are the deserts of iraq and syria
where pockets exists of icy we've been
hearing reports of thousands and
thousands of families belonging to
isil are being held camps in
the deserts of derazor as well as some
in iraq
and many international governments have
been reluctant to take back the fighters
so there there are some elements on the
ground isil has been defeated it does
not control any territory
but it is capable of carrying out small
operations as
pockets uh of uh armed fighters exist
in in in scattered areas uh sparsely
populated areas
across the iraq and syria desert all
right osama bin javed there at
san luis on the turkey syria border
osama for the time being uh thank you